i had a package come today from ups and
they'd been telling me that it was
on its way and then it got delayed and
it is from youtube so
i think i know what this most likely is
and i'm guessing many of you also know
what this is so why don't we take a look
inside the box
and see what we
actually have
i wanted to be able to share this with
my viewers since um i'm guessing it's
something that has a good bit to do with
youtube viewership
so we got this uh
really solid box here uh
i imagine it's probably important well
look at that it's got a little
black overlay so you can like have a
little reveal oh and there's
a
little
thing here from rick
who that's who inspected it
congratulations on your subscriber
milestone we're honored to take part in
recognizing your achievement and want to
your experience to be exceptional this
award was inspected and packaged with
great care by rick and then if it's
damaged i guess they'll fix it
there's a
thing here
signed by susan
wojcicki or however her name is
pronounced ceo youtube
some
100 000 subscribers just how far have
you come if each of your subscribers
were a light year they could take you
from one side of the milky way to the
other that's far
that's why today we're so excited to
celebrate your special youtube journey
with you not only have you brought a
unique voice and style to the world
you've also created valuable connections
and built a community along the way it
goes you know down further we can't wait
to see what you do next we'll be with
you every step of the way that's very
nice you know the ceo of youtube has
been watching my stuff i mean of course
not right
um and interestingly we're at a hundred
and uh
sixteen thousand subscribers
at this point
um
oh
i can allow my team i don't have a team
to purchase a personalized creator award
as well so this is actually quite a nice
box i might keep this and use it for
something else but here is the actual
award
so i'll let you take a look at that and
uh quite cool it's got things to hang it
on the wall
maybe i'll hang it over there by my
desk since i don't really have any other
place to put it but so it says presented
to gregory b sadler for passing 100 000
subscribers
youtube so that's you know that's cool
this is the silver play button and i've
had people asking me about this for
quite a while as i mentioned we're
already at 116 000 subscribers because
we passed
100 000 subscribers sometime last year
and we had a little party and stuff like
that online but it's nice to to finally
get the
award which is you know comes from
somewhere else it's subcontracted you
have to fill out a form and stuff like
that but there it is
so
very very cool
i'm glad that you could share that with
me and we could unbox it together i'll
just say
a few things you know thanks to
everybody who is a subscriber
um you know it's been 10 years 10 plus
years i got on youtube first
in
2010 uploaded my first video i think in
2011 in the spring the channel started
taking off with uploading philosophy
content and
you know by a few years in we're growing
pretty steadily and it's always been
steady growth since then some people
come in some people go out but more
come in and stay than than leave or have
accounts that are deleted or anything
like that so so this is really cool i'm
i'm glad to
get this i'm not usually a big
awards kind of person but i think
putting 10 years in
doing things like creating all these
different video series from
worlds of speculative fiction to half
hour hegel to the self-directed study to
core concepts to you you name it um
you know i think i i will say i think i
kind of deserve this
and it's it's cool to actually
have so glad all of you could share this
with me and that's pretty much all i
have to say on my end
you